je n'ai fait que révéler ce qu'ils
étaient des gens toi tu es ouvert les
yeux d'abord j'aimerais qu'on souhaite
la bienvenue à deux nouveaux élèves
maintenez le rite son frère je vous
laisse vous présenter à vos camarades
j'ai un peu d'avancé j'ai sauté des
classes magna lui les il est doux pour
plein d'autres choses
c'est comme si tout avait changé depuis
mon arrivée à aida
[Musique]
je suis devenu invincible
on peut dire que c'est ici que s'est
produit le dernier combat entre les
dieux et les géants
qu'est ce que vous savez sur eux ce
jeune homme qui vient d'arriver dans ta
classe je te garde un oeil sur lui lui
c'est fiore c'est un youtube le
troisième du nom toutes les filles sont
dingues de lui
le dissident qui parmi eux 10 humeur
pour ça faudrait déjà qu'on soit en
guerre les géants sont toujours parmi
nous les humains les regarde détruire le
monde sans rien faire aucun humain même
la force d'affronter seulement jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
là
une sainte virus ici
elle avait vu quelque chose là haut
nous n'avons pas eu d'ennemis comme lui
depuis au moins mille ans
[Applaudissements]
mais l'on mange les anneaux sauf si
quelqu'un b / on tue rectangle sous les
styles et je te garantis
moi qui courait et vous qu'il est fou
la quête de notre héros est sur le point
de débuter